TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hello, and welcome
to "The Developer Show."
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and I'm standing here
with Mary Grove, director
of Google for Entrepreneurs.
MARY GROVE: Hi, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, Mary.
How are you?
MARY GROVE: I'm great.
Thanks for having me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thanks for being here.
MARY GROVE: Absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Let me jump to a question
about Google for Entrepreneurs.
It's been on my mind
for a little while,
because developers ask
it, and I think it's fair,
and I think we should
give them an answer.
Why is Google doing this?
MARY GROVE: It's
a great question.
I'm glad you asked.
So there's two ways
that I look at that.
One is if you look at Google's
own history, our own journey
as a company, entrepreneurship
is such a core part of our DNA.
Google began as a
startup in a garage,
now almost 20 years ago.
We are a company founded
by entrepreneurs,
built by entrepreneurial
people, and it makes sense
that we are passionate about
empowering the next generation
of startups like Google to
become successful, to launch,
to use the internet to
grow their business.
So that's the first reason.
The second reason, though,
is actually an economic one.
We believe that by investing
in communities, long term
investing in
startup communities,
these are the next
set of companies
who are going to come
online, use the internet,
leverage Google's
products as well,
so really, it's this
notion that all boats rise,
and long, long term,
it's also going
to benefit our own business too.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Now before you were
the director of this
huge amazing thing,
you were a BD
principal at Google,
and I'm curious,
what did you learn
doing those global
partnerships that brought you
into this new job?
MARY GROVE: Sure.
So my actual, my personal
story with entrepreneurship
begins with my parents.
So my parents are both
immigrants from Thailand,
and they moved to
America, sort of
personified the
quintessential American dream.
They were entrepreneurs and
really showed me firsthand
that you can really
create whatever future
you dream for yourself.
So at Google, fast
forward many years later,
I was working in new business
development, as you said,
looking at emerging
markets for Google.
And everywhere we worked,
we looked for three things.
One is how can we increase
access, so internet and mobile
penetration.
Two is how can we
increase content created
from these regions,
and the third bucket,
which is my personal sort of
passion, was entrepreneurship.
So how can we work
with students,
developers in the emerging
entrepreneur ecosystem
to really help them create the
next generation of companies
and really create and
grow their own economies?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
let's say you're
a budding entrepreneur out there
with an early stage startup.
What's your first step
getting help from Google?
MARY GROVE: There's many
ways to look at that.
There are so many amazing groups
and networks that Google has,
of course, Google Developer
groups being one of them,
Women Techmakers being
another great example.
We at the heart of it
are a technology company,
so we hope that our
products, our platforms
can help you be successful.
Beyond that in the Google
for Entrepreneurs umbrella,
our mission is really
about bringing together
startup communities, so working
with partners of all types,
whether that's physical
space, co-working,
tech hub to accelerators
and educational curricula.
We try to knit together
this global partner
community of about
50 organizations
who are supporting
entrepreneurs,
so we encourage you to get
involved with one of them.
For example, Techstars is a
global accelerator running all
sorts of programs ranging
from startup weekend
to their vertical accelerators,
and you can find all these
resources on our website, which
is google.com/entrepreneurs.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Is there anything
else that you'd
like to say about the
program that you don't often
get to talk about?
MARY GROVE: I think that we're
based here in Silicon Valley,
but Google is truly
a global company.
The internet has really
democratized access
to entrepreneurship.
You can launch a company
from Sao Paulo, Brazil
and have users in Seoul,
South Korea instantly,
and so what I would
say is we passionately
believe that entrepreneurship
is thriving all over the world.
It's about getting more access,
getting more opportunity,
and helping companies really
go global from day one
and think about their
market opportunity
as not just their
city or their country,
but really the whole world.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Mary,
thanks for joining me today.
MARY GROVE: Thanks, Timothy.
Thanks for having me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: For
more information
about Google for
Entrepreneurs, make
sure to check out the show
notes for all the links
that you need.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]